interro surprise et aujourd'hui je vous
le dis celui qui va perdre devra faire
un truc pendant toutes les pubs sur
facebook live folie donc pendant les
pubs il fera pendant sept minutes
quelque chose je vais interroger
aujourd'hui mature
[Musique]
au tableau au tableau au tableau au
tableau pour que tout misé sur le
mauvais cheval mon grand hanouna de la
mondaine oued l'amener à travailler
ensemble alors les chéris j'ai des
questions il faut qu'ils aient la
moyenne ouais d'accord et un bisou dans
le cou oui j'espère que t'as pas la
gastro en revanche non pas du tout tu as
une tête à la voirie ce que tu veux
vérifier ou non merci c'est moi où je
peux plus je tiens regarde ça va être
calme et ça ça lui rappelle moufles
émission qui l'avait fait aller les
chéris ces questions pour lui dans
quelle émission sophie davant at elle
fait une blague en 1987 lors de la
présentation d'un bulletin météo aussi
bien pour les lions à l'oral aa et bien
je dirais matin bonheur et non c'était
quoi
télématin télématin tout simplement
alors qu'elle présentait la météo se
fier à un jeu de mots à 111 et j'ai pas
fait exprès du tout après huit chars est
malade
c'était très drôle ça roger zabel qui a
animé le programme à l'époque on l'a
déjà vu ça mais on ne s'en lasse pas
sophie arrêtez vous cachez pas on adore
regarder c'est parti c'est l'hiver qui
approche maintenant alors sophie surface
parce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire dans cette histoire est bien
entendu l'enjeu vous dirais qu'il
faudrait nous ressert très beau encore
plus jordi et
[Applaudissements]
alors expliqué parce que j'ai gardé ça
c'est même pas un pari mais il faut
expliquer moi j'étais là depuis trois
semaines j'étais pigiste une petite qui
débutait qui se lever tous les jours à
4h du matin pour être la leur et roger
faisait des blagues pour l'émission et
donc il raconte l'histoire des hussards
et des uhlans qui sont antagonistes de
père en fils qui peuvent pas se voir et
alors il raconte ça au maquillage âgé
d'à peine réveillé et il est midi ben
wallace et un nul en c1 c'est à us are
fatigué qui rencontra hulot et son dense
un bail gens peuvent pluies sont
désabusés et le hussard diaw lantus et
moi en tant qu ça on dirait que on
dirait que je t'aurais pas vu et on
arrête de se taper dessus je t'ai pas
vue et le curé pente en culotte je t'ai
pas vu non plus c'était la blague il
n'ya rien à comprendre
et il commence l'antenne il démarre
l'antenne à 6h30 du matin en disant en
tant que star bonjour madame donc tout
le monde se marre et je vais t'en
c'était quoi la bac et donc je
commençais météo je les entends plus
lent sans réaliser ce que je le dise non
dit ah oui boys et donc je vois que
c'est pas drôle du tout et je vois qu
orange et émergents s'est enfoncé dans
son fauteuil c'est pas possible elle l'a
pas dit l'a pas dit c'est babu là je
vois le rédacteur en chef françois
ponchaud les qui arrive échevelé et qui
m'était complètement folle ma peau fils
à papa on y passe la nuit qu'est ce que
j'ai dit et là une sorte de merde chaude
s'est mis à dégouliner sur ma tête j'ai
compris enfin la blague
oui histoire de blondes ou même jamais
ça va mais franchement ce riff c'était
sympa ça j'aime bien comme ça j'aurais
pu me faire virer les six mois oui mais
non là c'était 3 millions ça c'est clair
ça c'est ça c'est 3 millions c'est clé
sous la porte est terminé merci paris si
la soutenir une patate village parce que
je pensais qu'un images été détruites à
jamais non et ce moment-là pas des prix
on n'a pas des prix la tension mais il
pose une question dans l'émission c'est
au programme
sophie davant a chuté en testant un
objet ni au repos de quel objet
s'agit-il un lit en europe en baisse et
d'un lit d'un lycée mc
regardez et vous pouvez l'installer dans
votre jardin et surtout il à
l'emplacement pour m la lecture est pour
m la boisson donc c'est vraiment le donc
là évidemment nous assistons à un
accident gilbert sophie revenez chez
nous et on a besoin extrait très drôle
que c'est trop programme où il est
question de bananes regarder les balades
franchement impressionnant fin
ça c'est la banane légumes justement
fait le dire qu'elle et moi c est le
moins sucré au départ et plus elle mûrit
plus l'amidon se transforme en sucre et
c'est ça qui donne justement nos goûts
subtils
je crois que vous n'avez plus besoin de
carottes parce que vous êtes très
aimable sophie ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
anime près de vingt ans qu'elle aligne
sept au programme et oui autour des
bananes je sais la récession le produit
intéressés alors attention
pour l'instant vous avez zéro point je
sais jolie quelle édition d' aventure
sophie davant at-elle animé en 92 sur
antenne 2 avec grégory 30 au plus tard
alors là si le truc de zapata alors
c'est moi je prends la piste la plus de
gza patane bonne réponse je prends quand
même
et ouais c'était on peut le dire
l'ancêtre de koh lanta on regarde une
image de vous dans cette émission vous
expliquer une épreuve à des participants
c'était des animateurs ou pour une
spéciale que vous aviez fait regarder
les explications de sophie voulait
encore en fleurs fuchsia une fois tirer
plus fort que sur la corde si vous
n'êtes pas passés dans trois minutes
pour entrer dans la voiture ce qui n'en
parle pas trop de temps oui
la faute à des régions génial je
n'arrêtais pas de me faire engueuler par
jacques en train de producteurs ce que
j'avais des fous rires retard maintenant
parce qu'il était mort de rire il se lie
raté toutes les épreuves tombées tôt
mais bon y avait aucune force il se
faisait lacéré par le cavalier noir
enfin moi donc je rie et est donc
j'animais plus rien mais donc je vous
dis enfin il s'enferme s'il faut avoir
l'air sérieux il faut et moi je riais ol
souvenirs on se faisait des soirées
spéciales zapata non le voile a valu te
faisais des soirées spéciales mouche
mais ça ne trompe pas il faut dire qu'il
s'était trompé sur la saison des pluies
et qu'on était arrivés là-bas en pleine
saison des pluies la balance ça doit
être la saison sèche barbie savoir qu on
s'enlise et de quad est pas là mais mon
cousin mois une tablette de chocolat
comme ça ma poule comme ça giuly à
ouidah mais attention ça va chauffer
maintenant mais c'est comme dans les
z'amours bonnes réponses non mais qui se
faisait pas répondu non mais ça joue
maintenant si j'ai perdu c'est perdu
ok j'ai servi pendant toute la pub pour
quels types de produits sophie davant
tel fait une publicité
non je veux pas prendre ça va aller ça
me touche mais regardez les réponses
alors attention comme aller dans
télématin sophie davant reçu une
décharge électrique en testant l'objet
il s'agit d'une lampe d'un appareil
d'électrostimulation ou d'un sex toy
non alors eh bien il sait qu'il n'a pas
aidé électrostimulation on regarde là
démonstration démonstration on vous avez
des petites électrodes des électrodes
longtemps et la protection le biceps et
ensuite vous devez régler la puissance
de votre appareil des plus plus plus
plus plus plus ça va jouer sur cette
question quel animal est à l'origine
d'un fou rire entre sophie davant et
christine bravo mille à 2 sur 4 pour
l'instant faut que vous ayez besoin sur
saint paul vi de propositions non j'en
ai pas quel animal est à l'origine d'un
fou rire entre sophie davant et
christine bravo à notre ami
forcément les mâles qu'un truc car sexe
important à votre avis
l'animal un chimpanzé on vérifie shop
vous vouliez nous parler de votre chatte
isis qui est resté coincé pendant deux
semaines non non non 15 semaines
car même dans un gris un mois pile et le
jure qu au bout d'un mois j'ai sorti de
là une vieille fourrure éviter quelque
chose d'effroyable donc finalement il y
a dans toutes chatte qui sommeille un
survivant potentiel et ça c'est
important de savoir mathieu de l'an
passé mathieu